CNN which used to be a very reputable
news organization and now is a place for
Wolf Blitzer to putz around all day they
have joined forces with BuzzFeed which
is basically like the hottest thing
online and BuzzFeed is going to be
producing a couple videos for CNN each
week probably about three on a YouTube
channel and people are saying this is
gonna make CNN cool it's gonna give cred
to BuzzFeed I don't know that BuzzFeed
needs any more cred because I give
BuzzFeed a lot of cred do you guys think
that like old media and new media can
combine and not destroy each other
yeah I didn't think could I think it's a
good it's a better idea for CNN to put
BuzzFeed on their radar as opposed to
buzz to be putting CNN because when I
look at BuzzFeed articles I want to see
pictures with funny captions I don't
want to see news I don't want to see
videos yeah if I see if I click it and I
see oh there's a video oh no I don't
have time for that I want to just like
read a little funny pictures I want to
see 27 pictures of cute cats and dresses
by the way did you guys hear that last
week they announced that the dot gif
it's now it's pronounced gif oh you knew
that already because didn't the guy who
invented it or something he had he
officially laid down the law
it's Jeff I thought it was gift you know
is it does this tell you the state of
CNN and just news in general that they
have to combine with a site that really
is known for cat pictures honestly I
think it's more telling of the society
how much the status of news but it's
like how much attention span do we have
in this new like adderall induced youth
society of news you know I think it's
like how many images can we cram in over
sad music in a minute because I watched
the video yeah did you watch the V I
watched the video and I thought going
into it I thought so they put up one
piece right they put up one piece and it
was a montage of all the rescues of the
best rescues of 2000 whatever yeah and
so I was like going into it I'm like
this isn't gonna work for me like you
know and by the end of it I was like
no it's not something I don't know yeah
do you think it's bad for our brain
chemistry that even now we have to get
our news in such like I love Twitter I
say it every week on this show and I
tweet like crazy but like that actually
it might be doing something to our
brains that everything we do and you
talked about adderall a second ago that
everything we do is such quick short
bytes
and we're not giving ourselves like any
room in our brain to get those neurons
connecting to other things I blame it on
Sponge Bob Squarepants though they did
that study showing that kids that watch
that show like are more likely to
develop a TD really yeah unknown I've
only seen spongebob one choice but it's
a lot of quick yeah I watched it a lot
of the cave and I was diagnosed with a
DB really legitimately yes yeah so I
blame that do you believe spongebob
would and what do you think dude I don't
know what to blame mine on I didn't
watch Spongebob but I can only imagine
it was all the other horrible cartoons
that yeah yeah I don't know but you know
what I still feed into it those short
bursts of news yeah and Twitter and
Instagram things that you know your
brain is constantly working you never
get a chance to rest and really absorb
nowadays so I think that's their only
option yeah do you guys think it says
more about CNN or more about BuzzFeed
like to me this is this is CNN trying to
remain relevant yes not BuzzFeed trying
to get great because CNN has such a bad
reputation right now yeah I mean yeah
you're right people I feel the worst for
though are the content creators who like
because they're BuzzFeed is sharing
other people's stuff or you know they do
have their authors that that create
their own articles but I feel bad for
the videos that they pull CNN is gonna
take videos that people made and those
people aren't gonna get in the ad
revenue right CNN and BuzzFeed are gonna
get the road new and that's what bothers
me as a content creator right it's just
like I'm so used to other people taking
my money and that sucks right all right
well that's a slight sidebar but I think
that's kind of interesting so basically
what you're saying is they're gonna
embed all these clips but do they do it
in their own player is that
I usually take it from you too so if
they take it from YouTube aren't you
still getting the clips or the click oh
yeah no if they if it's yeah embedded
from YouTube on their site like BuzzFeed
you probably still get the the revenue
but on CNN is when they're playing
something like on TV yeah does this just
go to show that like big media will
destroy it this is sort of reminds me of
like yahoo and tumblr like we're just
waiting for tumblr to be destroyed now
and I feel like that's what you see in
it next up will be like Anderson Cooper
hosting Blue's Clues
you know yeah that would be good you
know his ratings are not good like why
not feel like why not just yeah yeah all
right Anderson there you heard it from
Whitney take 15% on the